vi chiedo di chiudere un attimo gli
occhi
chiudiamoli
e immaginiamo il primo la prima
fotogramma che ci viene e ci appare
durante la giornata quando usciamo di
casa quando usciamo dal letto quando
usciamo dal bagno quando apriamo la
finestra
qual è il primo fotogramma e c'era
l'esterno
una casa un muro un'api finestra un
albero un giardino una strada
ecco prendiamo quel fotogramma apriamo
gli occhi
teniamolo lì presente perché quello è il
primo segmento della nostra vita ogni
giorno è un luogo dove noi viviamo per
scelta perché il posto dove d'amore
deciso di vivere dopo oppure dove il
destino ci ha portato dove siamo nati o
dove siamo stati costretti ad arrivare
in alcuni casi è molto bello è un posto
molto bello ad altri altri casi è neutro
in alcuni casi è molto brutto è una
parete di cemento a pochi centimetri
magari dalla nostra finestra
ecco quello è il primo elemento del
nostro percorso perché il territorio è
il primo frammento il primo tessera di
un mosaico del territorio
adesso inseriamo il secondo elemento
che è quel pulviscolo di cosine che si
muovono intorno a quel territorio che si
chiamano esseri umani e sono tanti
tantissimi appena allarghiamo lo sulla
la visione e
soprattutto hanno dell'identità hanno un
nome cognome della storia di cui
normalmente a seconda di quel dove
viviamo e non sia un borgo di 30 persone
ma fanno città conosciamo pochissimo
quello è
il mondo delle persone delle identità
umane che si affianca alle identità dei
territori
hanno questa caratteristica in comune
hanno delle identità e insieme formano
una comunità
le persone hanno una comunità e si
inseriscono sul territorio
questo mix è qualcosa di magico che ha
delle potenzialità inespresse
straordinarie
esse riguardano quella dimensione di
lamentela tipica di noi italiani che è a
potremmo vivere della bellezza della
nostra terra a potremmo vivere il
turismo a bla bla bla bla bla
soprattutto quando andiamo all'estero e
vediamo un altra un'altra serie di
parole molto molto tipiche che ci viene
fuori ma naturali hansen per che cosa
fanno loro con poco che hanno
e ritorniamo sulla prima a noi potremmo
ok e perché non succede
perché il tema è quello perché questi
luoghi e siamo nel cuore della sicilia e
ogni siciliano sa quanto vale questa
terra
quindi tutto questo discorso fatto in
alto adige probabilmente no funziona
molto meno
qui lo senti sulla pelle ti brucia
questa cosa
perché non funziona
tanti motivi non c'è il tempo per
elencarli tutti ma uno importante sì
perché siano tutti questi elementi sono
disconnessi
siamo tessere sconnesse
siamo isole senza odi
e cosa succede che non riusciamo a
valorizzare quello che abbiamo
questo progetto di cui vi parlo stasera
un progetto di una comunità è il sogno
di una comunità che sta diventando
concreto in tempo reale
e si chiama museo diffuso dei cinque
sensi di sciacca
inizia tutto in un momento del 2019
all'inizio del 2019 quando
all'ennesimo cartello affittasi che
viene messo nei 100 di sciacca
una parte della comunità della cittadina
dice basta
non possiamo stare qui inerti e inermi
senza fare niente e decidono di muoversi
iniziano a
incontrarsi e trovano in una figura di
riferimento perché le figure sono
importanti le persone poi sono
importanti che decide di metterci la
faccia di dire adesso diamoci da fare 1
spinto questa percorso una si chiama di
viana rizzuto e ed è una di quelle menti
che tornano italia dopo aver fatto la
programma nagel a livello internazionale
per 15 anni e anche lei dice perché
riusciamo a far funzionare
multinazionali riusciamo a far
funzionare aziende in maniera pazzesca e
noi non riusciamo a farlo qui con le
risorse che abbiamo torna e nasce il
museo diffuso dei cinque sensi sciacca
40 mila abitanti
a un turismo strano perché mentre il
mondo cresce più 4 per cento all'anno di
turismo mentre la sicilia l'italia
cresce sciacca diminuisce e quel poco di
turismo che quel tanto di turismo c'è
perché sono i grandi alberghi fuori male
centro storico non si fermano i turisti
e massimo per una notte via tutti lì a
lamentarsi ma il punto di vista rovescio
cosa facciamo noi
perché un turista davvero interessante
si fermi giorni e giorni offriamo quello
che lui vorrebbe offriamo quello che noi
vorremmo trovare perché questo vale per
sciacca vale per jesi vale per
tantissimi dei posti della sicilia del
nostro sud italia ne abbiamo fatto tutto
quello che potevamo fare per valorizzare
il nostro territorio affinché diventi
un'esperienza indimenticabile di quelle
che racconti agli altri c perché non vai
forse no
allora nasce un percorso nasce nel 2019
all'inizio e diventa un museo diffuso
cos'è un museo diffuso l'idea di un
museo in cui le cinque porte del centro
storico di sciacca siano le cinque porte
di un museo che i corridoi siano le
strade siano i corridoi dove le piazze
siano le sale disposizione della del
museo e dove ogni finestra ogni vetrina
ogni in ogni saracinesca che apre si
apre ogni mattina sia una teca del museo
perché il tesoro da offrire alle per
mondo è l'identità di chi ci vive
questo diventa un tesoro ma per farlo
serve conoscenza serve consapevolezza e
non dei singoli ma delle comunità cos'è
la comunità sono sì persone connesse
quando una comunità di singoli
consapevoli si mesce diventa una
comunità competente consapevole e
competente e si offre al turismo
attenzione turismo e tanto di più che un
semplice albergo la ristorazione
soprattutto da noi
cosa produce quindi si connettono le
persone per creare economia per
permettere a quelle persone che abbiamo
sentito o che di cui si parlava anche
paola di che diano che si sono
allontanate di tornare è simone che
torna sono tutte le persone che tornano
trovano posto giusto per stare grazie
cosa alla valorizzazione del proprio
territorio della propria identità
e questo è percorso di mostra dei cinque
sensi che produce una comunità
ospitante i risultati
dell'elenco e potete verificarlo di
persona in due anni di co lead peraltro
il risultato di quest'estate siamo
abbiamo appena iniziato io sono il
direttore creativo di questo progetto
quindi per queste le parlò anche di
vendola
ogni giorno
il risultato è che la comunità
il gruppo si è ingigantito in epoca co
vide si è preparato si sapeva che a
sedere stato il momento di partire e
dalle parole passare ai fatti e oggi
quest'estate abbiamo messo alla prova
quello che ci auguravamo potesse
succedere oggi il museo diffuso di
sciacca comprende 110 operatori
commerciali ci sono 24 strutture
ricettive i bimbi però sono connessi e
succede uno dei piccoli miracoli nella
testa
l'albergatore è una delle figure
commerciali tipiche in cui odia quando
qualcun altro arriva perché è un rivale
il cliente che va da lui un cliente che
ho perso io e quindi lo odi speri che
gli venga qualsiasi cosa che bruci la
sua struttura magari così tu diventi
migliore ma oggi al contrario a sciacca
tutti gli operatori che fanno parte
della nostra struttura sono 24 su con
maggior parte dei bimbi
collaborano festeggiano l'apertura di un
nuovo c'è nel nuovo bmb si comunicano
nelle chat e i clienti se li passano
utilizzano le strutture di uno per
migliorare la propria offerta e questo
succede per gli artigiani che non sono
più degli artigiani della ceramica del
corallo o della cartapesta
caratteristiche che a sciacca ma ognuno
ogni territorio dei nostri nostri paesi
ha queste caratteristiche non sono più
solo degli artigiani che fanno turismo
esperienziale quindi accolgono
il cittadino temporaneo e gli fanno fare
il vasetto di ceramica con le sue mani
si chiama turismo esperienziale ma
finché ne parli è facile quando lo mette
in pratica devi cambiare atteggiamento
non sei più semplicemente un bravissimo
artigiano ma ti devi dimettere in
ascolto l'orchestra di cui si parlava
poco fa funziona perché c'è una sinfonia
di persone che ascoltano prima di
suonare quindi tu devi metterti in
ascolto cambi e la comunità diventa
accogliente come ci sono 10 info point
oggi diffusi ma non solo gli infopoint i
classici sono
un bar un pub un un tabaccaio un negozio
una agenzia di viaggi in centro nautico
che diventano info point e tifosi danno
le informazioni
ma sono soprattutto un presidio della
narrazione dell'identità fatta dai
cittadini e questo cosa succede cosa fa
cambia la testa di tutti
oggi abbiamo delle testimonianze di
viaggiatori italiani siciliani
stranieri che piangono perché piangono
dall'emozione perché sembra non sia
quasi vero che tu sei un post e la gente
ti accoglie tease dice as a benedica
qua che poi una parola che ha una
somiglianza no alla sala ma lei con e
torna tutto torna tutto
e ti senti davvero parte di un progetto
e la cittadinanza cambia e questo
significa essere una comunità connessa e
cosa succede che si sviluppano delle
situazioni molto strane perché nel
momento in cui si fa rigenerazione
urbana non è più solo rigenerazione
urbana che attiene la parte del mondo
dei beni culturali ma viene rigettata
una salita con delle ceramiche e la
comunità se ne occupa non persone del
museo diffuso
ma chi ci abita intorno annate alle
piante protegge i vasi
e cosa succede e turisti si fermano
fotografano un punto morto della città e
il tabaccaio ci dice che aumentato del
30 per cento e suo fatturato
economia società connessioni cultura
abbiamo riaperto le stufe le grotte
vaporose che era un bene del geologico
straordinaria chiuso da anni non c'è un
ritorno economico e senza ticket e come
fai grazie al fatto che ai 54
associazioni con cui sei connesso
intorno a musa diffuso ci sono decine di
associazioni
che fanno parte di questo e propongono
sostengono opere condivise ma questo
diventa attrazione turistica che aumenta
e inizia a salire al livello e torni ad
essere quella destinazione che avresti
sempre voluto essere di cui le persone
si fermano
l'albergatore ha certo punto dice
signora bene una notte
ve lo giuro tanto tutto monitorato lo
potete verificare davvero e la signora
dice bene grazie poi vado a taormina
vado su ragusa eccetera e il ri di
scelsi però comunque noi facciamo parte
di questo progetto se vuole di
all'occhiata e lei richiama dice ah che
bello mi prenoto altre quattro notti
economia areo viaggi che è un attore
importante tour operator decide di
aprire destagionalizzare aprì a gennaio
ma cosa fai fare le persone giornali non
è lo stesso bene se in sicilia ma non è
lo stesso modo di stare in spiaggia ma
se tu hai una comunità che ti fa fare
esperienze ogni giorno per più giorni
diventa utilità e quindi noi siamo utili
ero viaggi al viaggio è utile a noi
perché porta lavoro si connette
l'economia con la cultura con l'ambiente
con la società perché tutto questo e
coesione sociale
la comunità vive il proprio poste lo
migliora e un posto bello in cui vivi tu
è un posto bello in cui stanno arrivano
i turisti o cittadini temporanei e un
posto dove loro stanno meglio è un posto
di meglio tu e si cominciano a
realizzare quello che un ragazzo prima
diceva il proprio la propria passione il
proprio ruolo puoi essere te stesso e
questa economia reale
ci sono nuovi posti di lavoro
le nostre due vicepresidenti sono hanno
24 anni
di intorno li potrei farvi decine di
nomi di persone che fanno parte di
questo progetto
una comunità ha creduto in un sogno
e questo realtà oggi appena vinto un
premio due giorni fa che si chiama
welfare che impresa ed è uno dei più
importanti premi italiani con dove
c'erano e rami competizione con 158
start up abbastanza importanti grandi
delle fondazioni che hanno premiato sono
tra quelle più importanti italiane siamo
arrivati primi in italia ed è il quinto
sesto premio che prendiamo
siamo i migliori in italia dalla
provincia più sfigata d'italia secondo
quelle che sono alcune statistiche dove
alcuni solo alcuni parametri vengono
presi si dice noi siamo pronti
addirittura a replicare e c'è orgoglio
nel raccontare la propria città ecco
perché adesso torniamo un secondo a
quell'immagine ma occorre che chiudete
gli occhi però riprendete quel frammento
di immagine e se pensate che non possa
più essere modificato
ok io ho fallito probabilmente nello
spezzino talk
ma se dentro di voi quella stesso frame
quella stessa immagine adesso può
diventare qualcos'altro
allora abbiamo fatto un altro passetto
in avanti perché il segreto che
sta dietro tutto questo che è stato
messo in piedi
che la gente ha smesso di lamentarsi ha
iniziato a dire io voglio e posso fare
la mia parte e non solo per un motivo
altruistico
manca egoistico perché io voglio essere
felice
[Applauso]